NARRATOR: Machu Picchu, Peru.
This stone citadel of
the Inca civilization
was built high in the Andes
Mountains around 1450, AD,
but was suddenly and
mysteriously abandoned
roughly a century later.
Mainstream scholars contend the
construction of Machu Picchu
was led by Emperor Pachacutec,
and took thousands of men
working decades to complete.
But ancient astronaut
theorists suggest
that the precise construction,
the transportation
of massive blocks, and
the Incas' own accounts
all point to a very different
explanation for Machu Picchu--
that it was built with the
help of otherworldly beings.
Emperor Pachacutec
was believed
to have had a special bond
with the god Viracocha.
ED BARNHART: Pachacutec,
in the days leading up
to the great battle
against the Chanka,
he takes kind of a retreat.
He goes to a lake.
And out of the sky drops this
piece of metal into the lake.
When he fishes it out of
the lake, it's a mirror.
And he sees an
image in the mirror.
This supernatural creature
in the mirror tells him,
I am your father.
You will win many
battles in your lifetime,
this one included.
The image is actually
Viracocha, the creator deity.
And then, as Pachacutec stood
with his vastly smaller army,
these giant megalithic
stones came to life
and became his army.
They crushed the Chanka.
Pachacutec actually had the
power of Viracocha behind him.
It makes one wonder
if, in fact, this was
extraterrestrial technology.
NARRATOR: Could the
story of Pachacutec
levitating massive
stones be true?
And might the mirror
that fell from the sky
have been some type
of alien technology?
Ancient astronaut
theorists say yes
and suggest a new
discovery at Machu Picchu
may reveal what happened to
this otherworldly device.
French engineer David Crespi
was vacationing in Machu Picchu
in 2010 when he discovered
that, at the bottom of one
of the main buildings, there
seemed to be a doorway,
purposely sealed up with rocks.
In August of 2011,
he reached out
to Thierry Jamin, a
French archeologist that
has been studying Peru
and the Incan empire
for more than 15 years.
Within a month, Thierry
started his own investigation,
with local archeologists and
specialists in funerary sites.
Thierry and radar
technician Ricardo Hamada
took a scan from above
the blocked entrance
with ground-penetrating radar.
The image on the radar detector
reveals a large cavity.
And the broken
lines indicate there
may also be stairs, leading even
further down into the earth.
Other equipment detected
that there was metals
inside this hidden chamber--
gold, silver, and other
types of metallic objects,
suggesting very strongly
that we're dealing
with some kind of a tomb.
NARRATOR: Although Thierry has
confirmed Crespi's suspicions,
that the odd structure
was an entrance sealed off
at some point by the Incas,
the Peruvian authorities
have since banned his
returned to the site
for further investigations.
THIERRY JAMIN: [speaking french]
INTERPRETER: All of the
iconographic and archeological
elements show us that
this is all associated
with the mausoleum
of Pachacutec, maybe
the most important
archeological treasure
ever found in Machu Picchu.
NARRATOR: Could the
tomb of Pachacutec
lie beyond these rocks?
And is it possible, as ancient
astronaut theorists suggest,
that it might also contain
advanced technology--
the so-called magic
mirror that was
said to have been
given to Pachacutec
by the creator god Viracocha?